llegó la hora de la información
económica en france 24 me acompaña de
admira hablando nuestra compañera
especializada la batería dan y empezamos
hablando de eeuu y ese movimiento hacia
la obligatoriedad de la vacunación juana
puesto por un lado el gobierno va a
exigir que todos los empleados federales
y más de 17 millones de trabajadores de
la salud se vacunen contra el hobbit 19
y por otro lado el departamento de
trabajo emitirá una orden para que todas
las empresas con más de 100
colaboradores apliquen vacunas o
practiquen pruebas semanales todo dentro
de la estrategia para hacerle frente a
la variante del está en el caso de los
trabajadores federales tendrán 75 días
para recibir sus dosis y si no lo hacen
y no están exentos de vacunación pueden
inclusive llegar a ser despedidos las
medidas que dejarían al menos a dos
terceras partes de los trabajadores del
país esto quiere decir unas 100 millones
de personas y las autoridades dicen que
el 53 por ciento ya está vacunado pero
todavía faltan 80 millones de personas
por hacerlo tenemos que hablar de
de la y de la economía de este país
concretamente de la inflación que llega
al 500 por ciento y tenemos que aclarar
primero juan que en este país es muy
difícil conocer los datos
macroeconómicos a ciencia cierta en el
caso de la inflación ante la falta de
datos oficiales uno de los más
consultados es el del observatorio
venezolano de finanzas que agrupa varios
analistas independientes según su más
reciente reporte solo en agosto los
precios al consumidor subieron 10 6%
frente a julio y en lo corrido del año
han aumentado
470 por ciento pero si la comparación se
hace frente al mismo mes del año pasado
la variación sería de mil
743 por ciento este país está en un
proceso de hiperinflación desde
noviembre de 2017 y eso ha generado
también una fuerte devaluación de su
moneda local seguimos en la región pero
hablando de bolivia porque los
bolivianos ya pueden utilizar sus
ahorros pensionales lo lograron después
de protestas y de varios días después de
que el legislativo le diera el visto
bueno a la propuesta el gobierno
finalmente promulgó a regañadientes una
ley que permite el retiro total o
parcial de los aportes de la jubilación
de los fondos de pensiones se estima que
alrededor de un millón de ciudadanos
podría beneficiarse aunque el presidente
luís arce los invito a meditar si de
verdad lo necesitan para que no se
queden sin ahorros para la vejez en
concreto los mayores de 50 años que
tengan menos de mil 436 dólares pueden
retirarlo todo quienes tengan lo
equivalente hasta 14 mil 367 podrán
acceder al 15% y los que hayan ahorrado
más de eso podrían sacar un máximo de 2
mil 176 dólares está iniciativa juan no
es nueva en la región recordemos que
chile lleva por la discusión del cuarto
retiro y perú también hizo devoluciones
tema muy controvertido éste pasamos a
hablar de la economía de afganistán
porque naciones unidas- está insistiendo
en desbloquear fondos para este país la
onu advirtió que para mediados de 2022
hasta un 97 por ciento de la población
de afganistán puede haber caído en la
pobreza si no se aplican medidas
urgentes para responder a la crisis
el país por eso pido a la comunidad
internacional que libere los fondos
bloqueados tras la toma del poder por
parte de los talibanes
el propósito comprensible es negar esos
fondos a los talibanes de facto sin
embargo el efecto inevitable será una
grave recesión económica que podría
arrojar a muchos más millones de la
pobreza y el hambre puede generar una
ola masiva de refugiados de afganistán y
de hecho hacer retroceder a este país
generaciones enteras
danny indicadores económicos de este 9
de septiembre la bolsa de nueva york
cerró el jueves en rojo por cuarto día
consecutivo con los ojos de todo el
mundo puestos en el avance de la
variante delta y sus efectos sobre la
economía en américa latina' la bolsa
brasileña rebotó después de una pésima
jornada en miércoles en medio de
tensiones políticas en ese país
terminamos con la cifra del día 93
dólares este es un bono mensual promedio
que se comenzará a pagar por el gobierno
del líbano a las familias a partir del
próximo mes
es casi el triple del salario mínimo que
hoy es de unos 34 dólares y el
ministerio de economía no ha
especificado cómo lo va a financiar
teniendo en cuenta que las reservas
internacionales del banco central han
caído drásticamente y que el valor de su
moneda también se ha desplomado también
hablando muchas gracias gracias también
ustedes quédense en france 24
[Música]